nos dicen que algunas cajas de cierta
marca de cereal para el desayuno
incluyen en su interior un cupón para
una renta de vídeo gratis la compañía
que hace el serial afirma que se puede
encontrar uno de esos cupones en el 20%
de las cajas sin embargo con base en su
experiencia al comer cereal en casa un
grupo de estudiantes cree que la
proporción de cajas con cupón es menor a
0.2 este grupo de estudiantes compró 65
cajas de cereal para investigar la
afirmación de la compañía
los estudiantes se encontraron 11
cupones en total para las rentas de
vídeo gratis en las 65 cajas supongamos
que es razonable decir que las 65 cajas
compradas por los estudiantes son una
muestra aleatoria de todas las cajas de
este cereal con base en esta muestra
existe un respaldo para la creencia de
los estudiantes de que la proporción de
cajas con cupones es
0.2 presenta evidencia estadística para
sostener tu respuesta
como siempre pausa el vídeo y ver si
puedes resolverlo de hecho esta es una
pregunta que viene en el examen de pi
statistics que quiere decir ap
estadística vamos a ver trataré de
resolverlo como ustedes lo harían si
realmente estuvieran tomando este examen
lo primero que tal vez podrían decir es
cuál es nuestra hipótesis nula y nuestra
hipótesis alternativa bueno la hipótesis
nula podría ser lo que afirma la
compañía la cual dice que el 20 por
ciento de las cajas contienen un cupón
esa es nuestra hipótesis nula y nuestra
hipótesis alternativa sería lo que
sospechamos es decir que la verdadera
proporción de cajas con cupón en
realidad es menor al 20% ahora sí vas a
hacer una prueba de significancia es
bueno establecer primero el nivel de
significancia con el que vas a comparar
tu valor de p
digamos que queremos suponer suponer que
el nivel de significancia lo escribiré
nivel de significancia alfa digamos que
es 0.05 y después vamos a pensar en la
muestra
entonces si suponemos que nuestra
hipótesis nula es correcta
necesitaríamos saber cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener la proporción de
la muestra que tenemos y si eso se
encuentra por debajo de este nivel de
significancia entonces rechazaremos la
hipótesis nula ahora lo que sabemos
sobre la muestra es que tenemos 65 cajas
de serie n es igual a 65 eso es lo que
nos dicen aquí y a partir de eso podemos
calcular cuál es la proporción de la
muestra que en este caso es de 11 sobre
65 usemos la calculadora podemos usar
calculadora en esta parte del examen
vamos a ver tenemos 11 entre 65
eso es igual a tomando solo tres cifras
significativas es igual a cero punto 169
entonces esto es aproximadamente igual a
cero punto 169 digo aproximadamente
porque lo redondeamos bien lo siguiente
que necesitamos hacer es asegurarnos de
que tenemos las condiciones para poder
llevar a cabo una inferencia lo
escribiré condiciones para inferencia y
esto es para estar seguros de que
nuestra distribución muestral sea
aproximadamente normal entonces la
primera condición es que sea una muestra
aleatoria aquí nos lo dicen supongamos
que es razonable decir que las 65 cajas
compradas por los estudiantes son una
muestra aleatoria así que se satisface
esta condición la siguiente condición es
la condición normal en donde se requiere
que la forma sea aproximadamente normal
y no muy asimétrica de una manera u otra
a cumplir esta condición necesitamos que
la multiplicación del tamaño de la
muestra por la proporción real supuesta
sea mayor o igual a 10 y además que n
por uno menos la proporción supuesta sea
también mayor o igual que 10 como vamos
a suponer que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera podemos decir que esta es la
proporción supuesta en la hipótesis nula
eso es lo que significa esta anotación
si haces esto en el examen tienes que
explicar tu notación un poco mejor
yo lo dejo así por cuestiones de tiempo
vamos a ver en ese 65 entonces tenemos
65 por la proporción supuesta que es 0.2
esto es igual a 13 y 13 es sin duda
mayor a 10 esto está bien y después
tenemos n es decir 65 por 1 - la
proporción supuesto eso es igual a 0.8 y
eso es igual a vamos a ver
a 65 13 y eso es igual a 52 sin duda es
mayor a 10 eso cumple con la condición
finalmente tenemos la condición de
independencia no estamos muestreando las
cajas con reemplazo así que necesitamos
asegurarnos de que representan menos del
10% de la población de cajas no nos
dicen eso explícitamente pero sería una
buena práctica decir que vamos a suponer
vamos a suponer más de más de 650 cajas
en la población lo que implica que n es
menor o igual al 10% de la población
esto cumple la condición de
independencia entonces como ya hemos
cumplido las condiciones para la
inferencia ahora pensemos en la
distribución muestra
distribución
muestral de proporciones de la muestra
porque eso es lo que vamos a usar para
calcular el valor p ya conocemos algunas
cosas sobre la distribución muestral de
las proporciones de la muestra sabemos
que la medida de la distribución
muestral es la proporción verdadera
supuesta que es la proporción de la
hipótesis nula y sabemos que la
desviación estándar de la distribución
muestral de las proporciones de la
muestra es la proporción supuesta por
uno menos la proporción supuesta de la
hipótesis nula entre n que en este caso
es igual a 0.2 por 0.8 y todo eso entre
65 usemos la calculadora vamos a sacar
la raíz cuadrada de abrimos paréntesis
0.2 por 0.8 entre 65 y eso es igual a
0.0 496 entonces esto
aproximadamente igual a cero punto cero
496 bien el siguiente paso es calcular
el valor p y después compararlo con el
nivel de significancia para decidir si
rechazamos o no la hipótesis nula para
calcular el valor p primero necesitamos
calcular el estadístico z que se refiere
a cuántas desviaciones estándar sobre o
por debajo de la media de la
distribución muestral se encuentra la
muestra estadística que obtenemos para
esta muestra de 65 y ya lo hemos visto
en vídeos anteriores esto es igual a la
proporción de la muestra menos la
proporción supuesta para la población en
la hipótesis nula y esta diferencia la
dividimos entre la desviación estándar
de la distribución muestral de las
proporciones de la muestra esto nos dice
cuántas desviaciones estándar estamos
por encima o debajo de la media de la
distribución muestra
6 en esta situación en particular esto
es igual a cero punto 169 menos 0.2 y
todo eso entre este valor que es de
aproximadamente 0 punto cero 496
nuevamente usemos la calculadora tenemos
0.169 menos 0.2 esto nos dice que tan
abajo se encuentra nuestra proporción
muestral con respecto a la media de la
distribución muestra que es la
proporción supuesta en la hipótesis nula
la proporción de la población supuesta y
eso lo dividimos entre la desviación
estándar de la distribución muestra
entonces lo dividimos entre 0.0 496 y
así es como obtenemos este valor
aproximado de set
digo aproximado porque recuerden que
estamos usando muchos valores
aproximados así que obtenemos
aproximadamente menos 0.625
z es aproximadamente igual a menos 0.625
ahora si podemos pensar en el valor real
de p vamos a ver el valor p es igual a
la probabilidad de obtener una
proporción muestral que sea al menos tan
baja como la que obtuvimos es decir
0.169 suponiendo que la hipótesis nula
es verdadera suponiendo que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera esto es igual a la
probabilidad de obtener el estadístico
set que es menor o igual a este valor
menos 0.625 vamos a usar la calculadora
para conocer el valor de esto lo que
podemos hacer es seleccionar la opción
de segunda distribución vamos a elegir
la distribución normal se de efe y
después vamos a decir que el límite
inferior que sería lower bound en la
calculadora es menos infinito y nuestro
límite superior que sería o perdón
- 0.625 bien podríamos decir que esta es
una distribución normal así que vamos a
continuar con el estadístico set damos
clic en enter y así es como obtenemos
este valor vamos a redondear lo a 0
punto 266 esto es aproximadamente igual
a cero punto 266 verifiquemos lo que
acabamos de hacer esta de aquí es la
distribución muestra supuesta de las
proporciones de la muestra en donde
tomamos como cierta la hipótesis nula
así que nuestra medida de la
distribución muestral será nuestra
proporción supuesto lo que estamos
diciendo es que obtuvimos un resultado
por aquí aquí es en donde se encuentra
nuestra p con sombrero cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un resultado tan
por debajo de la proporción real o aún
más bajo bueno eso es justo lo que
acabamos de calcular podemos ver que
corresponde aproximadamente a una
probabilidad del 27%
y comparamos el valor pe con el nivel de
significancia podemos ver claramente que
nuestro valor p es mayor al nivel de
significancia es decir que 0 punto 266
es claramente mayor que el nivel de
significancia de 0.05 lo que estamos
diciendo aquí es que si hubiera menos de
un 5% de probabilidad de conseguir la
proporción de la muestra que obtuvimos
entonces rechazaríamos la hipótesis nula
lo que sugeriría la hipótesis
alternativa pero aquí la probabilidad de
obtener la proporción muestral que
obtuvimos suponiendo que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera es casi del 27% y eso
se encuentra muy por encima de nuestro
nivel de significancia por lo que no
podemos rechazar no podemos rechazar la
hipótesis nula hipótesis
por lo tanto podemos decir que no hay
suficiente evidencia no hay suficiente
evidencia para sugerir para sugerir
nuestra hipótesis alternativa
si tienes tiempo tal vez también podrías
escribir en el examen que no hay
suficiente evidencia para sugerir que
menos del 20 por ciento de las cajas
contienen un cupón de renta de vídeo
gratis como lo dice la descripción del
problema esa sería nuestra respuesta nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo